comment ça va sur le plan sentimental
depuis que vous êtes une star ça va
parfaitement bien
ah oui beaucoup mieux ouais c'est un peu
étrange parce que les échos quand on est
un peu plus exposé médiatiquement on est
un peu connu par tout le monde comme ça
les gens s'approprient très vite notre
image
du coup on est tout de suite familier
avec les gens et les rams et qui disait
maintenant depuis je suis connue la
france c'est mon quartier c'est juste
qu'on est chez nous même à quimper ou
dans des endroits la façon dont je peux
même pas soupçonner l'existence comme je
sais pas le berry ou des trucs comme ça
là bas même là bas faire détester dans
toute la france va lancer deux régions
par mu alors qu'avec les gonzesses plus
besoin de faire des plans d'attaqué des
stratégies n'ont jamais besoin de ça ah
ouais j'ai tout de suite moi toute façon
physiquement bombe avec petit avec des
grandes oreilles je crois qu'on peut
donc il a fallu que je suis compense
avec d'autres attributs qui ne se
bonifie avec le temps qu'ils sont là la
parole la présence d'esprit s'il
tellement la mort quand même supplie de
l'embrasser alors votre grand père vous
a dit la femme de ta vie aura aucun
effort à faire danser tout quand même
vous tenez ça ben moi je peux être au
maire de grand père enfin moi j'habite
argent de temps faut dire allaoui dont
61 bah oui donc ouais mon papier me
disais ça et je ne sais pas si ségo quoi
j'ai super confiance sur mon grand père
mais donc du coup je ne fais aucun
effort et je suis célibataire
il
alors en plus vous aurez du succès au
cinéma plus vous serez beau et plus vous
serez beau plus vous aurez de femmes et
pour vous y habituer je vous faire une
interview alain delon
vous êtes prêts il est prêt ouais votre
conception du luxe et boire du coca dans
un verre en cristal ou boire du petrus
dans un gobelet en plastique
enfin il pense que c'est boire du et
russes dans un verre en cristal
ouais il avait fait pour faire du social
nous augmenterions et les salaires ou
vous diminuerez le temps de travail il
très peu concernés par la question
il dira qu' il va augmenter les salaires
mais il ya ces démagogues assez une
période électorale
oui il a besoin de se faire il a besoin
de se faire aimer par là j'aurais été
donc qui va dire il augmente les
salaires ils diminuent tous les impôts
et il offre une maison mobalpa ou maison
témoin dôme expo à qui veux pas qu'ils
votent pour lui
nouvelle pour taper la frime vous
préféré rouler sans bornes en ferrari
avec un boudin ou dix bornes contracteur
avec un top canon étant donné qu'il
vient de la sarthe
il va répondre qui va préférer être avec
un super beau tracteur qui déglingue je
ramasse et ferguson qui est aussi bon
qu'une ferrari est plus chère avec un
canon énorme kommissar tout ça sans
douille lisse vous pour vous le plus
chaud que tient à préciser que ça vous
super cher un tracteur ouais c'est du
luxe oui je sais je le vis bien
qu'encore des boeufs argentan des vols à
bas continue et il vous en prie il vous
écoute avec un plaisir non dissimulé
pour nous le plus choquant c'est
l'interdiction des mariages homos ou la
banalisation des divorces hétéro
il a il a envie de répondre autre chose
il envie de répondre qu'il comprend
toujours pas comment ça se fait qu'avec
la télé soit toujours pas marie et
encore ouais donc
il va répondre un truc complètement à
côté quoi s'est il est très jaloux des
deux noms quoi qu'il arrive parce que
lui seul et il est toujours pas
concernés par ce genre de dilemme elle
en lui beaucoup pour garder celle que
vous aimez vous préféreriez l'enfermer
dans un palais où la sortir des clubs
échangistes
ils préféreraient les deux il ferait
tout ouais ouais il sortirait la
surmultipliée et si vraiment il n'ya pas
le choix il n'en fermerai dans un palais
parce qu'il n'a pas trop confiance en
lui
salut
la lettre à sa belle-fille du cinéma
français il ya tout le monde